and my fear was that I would lose my
mind my friend there's just a new book
that came out by the daughter of Harold
the guy that was arrested with me well
he sent her letters and we were
separated in the Unites States right he
went to a gentleman he sent her letters
relating all of the tortures he went
through and she I read my book and when
she read my book she's like God man he's
like um believe what they went through
what these guys went through my father
and George and my fear was there was
this guy in a cell cross now this cell
had no bathroom no toilet no water sink
no nothing there was a spigot of water
that would come from the ceiling in
there whenever they open it had bugs and
it was a throw at the end of the cell
where once a week they would take a fire
hydrant holes and just flush all that
[ __ ] out so it was excrement all over we
smell like we smell like horrible and I
remember there was this around you at
this point I just turned 23 23 I think
there was a little rat that was coming
around us right and I kept looking at
him like Mickey if they don't get me out
here soon I'm gonna eat your ass right
now you're my only companion but I'm
gonna eat you and Oh No so he so I see
this guy crossed this dungeon right and
uh you can read about the Joker's it's
very infamous kolja Morello from the
eighteen hundreds and he kept all day
long he had been to six-month and kept
all day long just licking the bars right
he's just totally lost his mind
and my whole thing is I'm gonna die I
wanted to kill me but I can't lose my
mind I can't sit in like a vegetable and
you know how my parents wiped my butt
and all that crap so when we just
couldn't take anymore
one of the beatings I told her God
listen turn Noriega to kill me because
if you don't kill me he knows that I got
the power that when I get out of here
I'm gonna rape his family I'm gonna kill
him and then I kill him well I knew for
sure right that you told him tell it's
Nuria yeah and I just knew for sure he
would kill me and sure enough the next
day he comes but the funny thing is
I hadn't sold this feeling of relief I'm
about to die and it's good you know I'm
fine with that
well he comes laughing and he comes up
to me like why are you threatening me
I didn't tell on you threatened your
pilot's right he's saying by the way you
paid the wrong guy yeah I'm like how
much I knew that was a clue that was
hearing me that I should've paid him he
says 250,000 I said let me ask you
something is that like a going price
here in Panama because I paid the other
guy 250 for 4 and now we just do other
things still the same price he laughing
he's like so we went to the same routine
right and today later he came in goddess
they took they took us to this room and
they and they washed us down with his
fire Wallis's now if you're a guy here
was a fire that's when we see protester
get hit with fire hoses the tortures
were nothing compared to the fire no
water oh my god now what a full force on
your body is just like bullets coming at
you ripping your skin apart is horrific
so he takes us to the airport we're
sitting there waiting for an airplane to
come to Miami I mean to Costa Rica and
also I see like 15 Interpol agents then
it has my name or nothing they picked me
up like a sack of potatoes now way at
that time 180 185 and they threw me in
an airplane to Miami I got to Miami DEA
and all I was waiting there take us to
the court and I get charged with heading
the largest drug conspiracy in the
history of America I'm given a seven
million dollar bond they used that
specific language yeah now think about
this seven million dollars then in court
we got it down to two million but you
only you only get bail denied if you
murder someone your danger to the
community
right mmm now I'm saying to myself I'm
23 I don't have a freakin speeding
ticket I got a family I got a college
degree I can substantiate my lifestyle
you know I pay taxes
thousands I pay hundreds of thousand
there were two taxes yeah yeah goodbye
then you paint Fifth Amendment source
income right and you pay taxes I said I
could ponding go to jail for selling
alcohol you went to jail for taxes so
I'm not gonna go to jail for taxes I'm
making up money ain't this is another
business paid taxes and I did and and
then we challenged it right cuz we have
a constitutional right to bail and
because why am i a danger to the
community first of all the drugs
disappeared Noriega sold them so then he
had drugs then you have a wiretap then
you have a picture so they have me there
on a sworn complaint which me knowing
diamond nothing
mm-hmm I hired the best attorneys in the
world right I had Alan Dershowitz
I had a Marty Weinberg I had Shelby
Heisman who became a judge a federal
judge in Miami his bill in law was one
of the chief judges in the appellate
court but these Miami guys marty was out
of Boston okay I mean Marty took me in
that time $25,000 just to tell me
whether he would take the case on that
and then so I paid a million dollar with
the lawyers at that time ten million
dollar day fifteen million dollar and so
we went to fight the bail right and we
hire Alan Dershowitz what you seen them
all over the place now and famous
Harvard professor and we knew that we
would get it because how can they say I
haven't killed anybody
you know I'm alleged to be a drug dealer
but there's no drugs so but a federal
judge issued this ruling in this court's
opinion mr. Valdez is not only a danger
to his community his community being the
whole United States and based upon that
is why drug dealers don't ever get bail
any more because up to that time
everybody got bail a murderer
got $100 bill was huge a kid twenty
three-year-old two million dollars
unheard of and six months later
seven more later no indictment they take
my case in front of a grand jury in
Miami would indict me a grand jury in
Central Florida will not indict me I
rendered in northern Florida will not
indict me
the judge finally says if you have an
indictment about Wednesday I'm gonna cut
him loose right right that's it they
help me six month on a complaint right
so I go to court and the judge has the
prosecutor the other indictment says no
we don't pick again and I mean it was
nothing what could they indict me for
you know they'd have nothing right so
they go ahead and I'm like I start
killing my parent but to walk out of the
car here comes a marshal arrest him
arrest him he's just been indicted in
the Northern District in the Middle
District of Georgia in Macon Georgia how
they make it you how do you know what
the hell that is
no been there my life so what ends up
happening is Harold Rosenthal the guy
that that I hired to bring the pilots in
he had a case pending of which even
faked his death so when we came to
United States the judge looked at him
and said well welcome back mr. Rosenthal
said your honor
I'm the second you to come back from the
dead everybody just cracked up and so
anyway they made me that I was their
supplier but I only met these people and
now it's a case three years prior the
guy faked his death left and disappear I
just met him two months earlier right
right so we are elders lawyers and our
defense was that we're gonna go in there
and confess that I'm a drug dealer
oh by the way they go and they lure that
captor of the Bolivian Air Force they
lure him to Panama and the arrest of
empowerment bring into a state and say
here's the guy that sold this goes to
George and the guys not cooperating I
put this his attorney so we go in there
and I and we talk yeah I'm a drug dealer
I'm the biggest drug dealer in America
but we were we were fighting the case
not to win a trial
we thought we could but we thought there
was a great chance we can't because a
Cuban in Macon Georgia there's no way
with an all-white jury right you know
yeah so that's what we're fighting to
win an appeal on the venue okay
in other words you got again you have a
constitutional right to be tribal you
commit your offense you cannot do sell
drugs here right now in
Tampa and be charged in California all
this is a venue to California right hmm
the buyers coming from California or
whatever so we're like I'm a drug dealer
and the biggest drug dealer in America
but you have no right to climb me in
Macon Georgia you know trying to climb
in Miami that's the only place you
allege that re-form bastards hotel on
Easter day I pop out this map of
Colombia right the cafeteria is like
like this right everybody sitting next
to each other in the cafeteria and I
tell this pilot this is where we're
gonna go to pick up the cocaine that was
the whole indictment against me wow that
was a whole indictment that's it
[Laughter]